that's the first thing but there's other
things that we care about this is well
I'm going to be to other implications
before we do this example question okay
so the first implication is can you go
ahead can you differentiate this for me
it only take you one line pretty much
just go ahead and differentiate for me
my time
[Applause]
[Applause]
you have the genitive you happy obvious
not very conservative is it okay now
what does it do me to tell you go back
to the first principle what's the point
of the derivative who was it it's the
gradient function very good now in the
context of a projectile write the
gradient function you can this is
probably worth drawing you know if you
had just a regular projectile go ahead
and roll them so it starts at the origin
okay now the grain function at any given
point is going to tell you how steep
this line is right now what's another
question that you get frequently asked
apart from like where is an object where
it's a projectile
you also often get asked prisoners and
it looked like this what is it - this is
birthing that transmission before what
is the angle of inclination that changes
doesn't it right you've got an initial
angle of projection right but then as
you go you know some point in flat at a
certain point you go down with all that
company so I could say for instance when
you are at a certain point at a given
value of x what is your angle and
inclination okay now normally you have
to go through time and actually be
awkward you have to find when it
happened you have to put into it rains
but here you just need to know what you
are right if I asked you for example
suppose this was that x equals 3 okay
what would you do to find out that angle
of inclination okay get a sum in here
right so you're going to get some value
added this not do something to you all
of that okay and then you hear DUI on DX
equals something now that's not the
angular momentum what would you do with
that it's it's enough up and you have to
you actually should calculate
what do you do do you have to use angles
of inclination you can at least hand
right you're gonna say M equals 10 you
know that's pretty nice interview and
you just found em by putting X equals
whatever you want into this number does
that make sense
so this is an alternative way of finding
out that angular inclination
you just have to appreciate was and it's
a very easy okay now the next thing
which takes me to where I posted the
last minute here we're going to do there
is this question I keep on posting to
you which is which is where you'd land
like 90% of prevent all motion questions
will say what do you learned
okay it's such a frequently knocks okay
in other words what is the impacts point
so I want you to have a think for a
minute I think you have everything on
the board that you need what would you
do with the equation of public how could
you use it to work out what you'll
impact point you I'm gonna give you some
time
I think it'll take me about 34 minutes I
think once you've worked out how you can
do to actually do it and I want you to
go ahead and see if you can find out
what the impact point is if you're not
sure you know I got it I don't even know
where to start
think about it you've got this beautiful
long equation which is taking time
completely and now you can use that to
find this but how did you do it
I've used some time to battle me
eventually I'll do it back if you don't
finish so there we go now it's it's
completely large that's okay well I'll
zoom out a second I just won't wait
spoilers so what have I cited to do well
we handled osius that this is a
quadratic equation right so therefore I
could use the quadratic formula well
anything I went to do that because I
don't always usually quite up on that
when I try to solve a quadratic equation
what's my other sort of more
coefficients like I would usually
factorize in my hand
do you think I'm gonna Becker eyes goal
these things thank you
right so here's where I launch into the
quadratic form I want to point out a
couple of
reporter 94 begins minus B plus or minus
the square root of now just have a look
at what the tissues you've got B squared
minus what comes after that
indiscriminate for AC but look carefully
and zoom at look carefully at what your
equation is right here's your a here's
your baby
what's C it's zero so that's why even
the distributor that is you know
there we go you get CP 0 so that's why
this for a sec pod just vanishes which
is drought relief because anyways right
now you can't get away from here there's
my 2 a on the denominator but basically
it's actually do pen out even though one
too terrible to begin with right you can
see at the top you the square root of 10
square is going to be the absolute value
of 10 out but you could start talking
about that but now there's an alpha
contain and therefore the values at an
alpha could take but in the end it
doesn't matter because you're doing plus
minus anyway so you take bro cases does
that make sense because it's incremental
you can see my choose have cancelled
down the bottom and then we get a look
at this you like wait a second my shoe
answers well of course I have two
answers because there are two places
that this is going to solve for but this
is going to solve for the origin and
also for the point of impact so those
are going to be our two solutions so you
see if I have scroll down just a teeny
bit you can see here are my two
solutions for my plus or minus case you
can see that guy over there is just
going to end up trivial because I have
this vide right up there just cancel
itself out so you have 0 and then over
here you get this now these stores all
look very pretty but because of all
these trig ratios and your fractions on
fracking I can still work on it further
yeah so you can see that what this is
this is the projection point this is
where I started x equals zero and once I
simplify this
this will be the point of impact this is
what I'm after right so you can see if
you get that sex with up on the top it's
really a cos squared on the top pan
alpha times cos square alpha one of
their cosines will cancel leave just a
sign right but this is something you
also recognize right this is a tree
identity that you work very very early
on right that's just like it's about Bob
now I just want to point out what this
means
what's the point of this the point of
this is right now can find out where the
projectile impacts the ground in terms
of what was one of the three things I
need to put it to you
evolution I need to be sure you go yeah
there you go
I need the additional stay right monster
fire and it means my gravity okay now
each of these things are constants which
you get given right at the beginning how
else would you find the impact point if
you weren't using the equation of path
well I've written over here right what
you have to do is you have to go all the
way through from from velocity and angle
and gravity you've got to go through all
six of those equations there to find out
what they are run over land then you
have to solve with y equals zero what is
that mean - it means you've it's the
exit if you come back to the ground by
your solve that but then what does that
give you it gives you a time because you
have time equation six of them right
then what you do with that time because
you're looking for any pathway you
substitute it into X then then the Sun
sets and then these ends okay so you
can't do that sometimes you have no
choice
sometimes you're required to do that
through sofox but if you can before
you're asked for is the impact point and
you're given initial velocity initial
angle then you're there just it's a
pretty simple equation it's a very
elegant way to do it okay so after all
of that work going through those six
equations you can actually
the suspensions out of the running if
you actually go ahead and use this
result it doesn't forget like I mean GG
it's often prove it that's also not a
question so there does this make sense
can we just back up for a second what is
this all about
the equation of pop or this there we go
there's the equation apart right then we
care about it because when you're asking
questions of where things I have to
either can't win then you don't need to
worry about time but in fact it's much
more efficient you talk very about time
and obviously prove things like this it
gets you to like simple results like the
derivative gives you the angle of
inclination and solving the quadratic
gives me